And then you
have Yeah.
How did I do this? I don't think
early
church
like it owns.
There's like a
whole Thursday.
So a little higher
than I
can ask.
All right, everybody.
Welcome to Palm Sunday at the table.
This is always a good time. If uh you
never been with us for Palm Sunday,
well, you're in for a treat. So this is
uh this kind of basically this moment
remembers the time when Christ himself
entered Jerusalem and of course all the
the people were there waving palm
branches right I know we don't have a
lot of these in Texas but there
Jerusalem this is like a popular kind of
tree so people are chanting those and
praising God and waving these around so
to participate and the thing is it
doesn't work if you don't like fully
give yourself to it so it can't be like
Hey, plus like you can't be lame about
this. You have to play it up. You have
to get into it and uh you know pretend
like you're there and enter it into the
story, so to speak. So, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to read a section of
Psalm 118 and then we're going to march
our way in there. We're going to make at
least two laps around then you can take
then I'll let you take a seat. Okay. But
not until two laps. You got you got to
play it up. All right. So this is Psalm
118:es 1-2 and
19-29. Give thanks to the Lord for he is
good. His love endures forever. Let
Israel say, "His love endures forever.
Open for me the gates of the righteous.
I will enter and give thanks to the
Lord. This is the gate of the Lord
through which the righteous may enter. I
will give you thanks for you answered
me. You have become my salvation. The
stone the builders rejected has become
the cornerstone. The Lord has done this
and it is marvelous in our eyes. The
Lord has done it this very day. Let us
rejoice today and be glad. Lord, save
us. Lord, grant us success. Blessed is
he who comes in the name of the Lord.
From the house of the Lord, we bless
you. The Lord is God and he has made his
light to shine on us. With boughs in
hand, join in the festal procession up
to the horns of the altar. You are my
God and I will praise you. You are my
God and I will exalt you. Give thanks to
the Lord for he is good. His love
endures forever. Hosana.
[Music]
[Applause]
Sam,
how are
[Music]
you? You got
to get back to
[Music]
worthy of all our praises.
Hosana.
Hosana. Come have your way among us. We
welcome you here, Lord Jesus.
Last time.
Hosana. Hosana.
You are the God who saves us. Worthy of
all our
praises.
[Music]
Hosanana.
Hosanana. Come have your way among us.
We welcome you here Lord Jesus.
Onees
rising, eyes are turning to
[Music]
you. We turn to you.
Hope is
stiring. Hearts are yearning for you.
We long for you.
When we see you, we find strength to
face the day. Go and stand with us.
In your presence, all our fears are
washed
away. Wash
away. Hosana.
chosen. You are the God who saves us.
Worthy of all our
praises.
[Music]
Hosanana.
Hosana. Come have your way among us. We
welcome you here, Lord
Jesus.
[Music]
Hear the sound of hearts
returning to you.
We turn to you.
In your
kingom.
Broken lives are made new.
You make us new.
[Music]
Cuz when we see you, we find strength to
face the day.
In your presence, all our fears are
washed
away. Washed
away.
[Music]
Hosana. Hosana.
You are the God who saves
us. Worthy of all our
praises.
Hosana.
Hosana. Come have your way among us. We
welcome you here Lord Jesus.
[Music]
All
right, excellent job. You kiddos are
dismissed to go to your classrooms and
your teachers will meet you over by the
doors. Thank you guys.
And today on this um special celebration
of Palm
Sunday, we're going to have a call to
worship that's slightly different than
our prayers of the people. So if you
guys would just
listen. Today we join Jesus in the final
ascent to
Jerusalem, knowing the depths that we
will descend on our journey through Holy
Week.
Open the gates of righteousness that we
may come and worship
God. We join the disciples in declaring
that Jesus riding on a donkey is our
ruler, the one who will bring peace and
salvation for
all. Open the gates of peace that we may
come and worship
God. We join with the bystanders who
questioned and wonder who this Jesus
really is. who feared the consequences
of angering the powers that be. Open the
gates of truth that we may come and
worship God. The journey through Holy
Week brings us face to face with the
stark reality of our sin and God's
faithfulness to
save. Open the gates of salvation that
we may come worship God whose steadfast
love never fails.
[Music]
Here is where I lay it down. Every
burden, every crown. This is my
surrender. This is my
surrender. Here is where I lay it down.
every lie and every doubt. This is my
surrender. And I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for
[Music]
you to do whatever you want
to. To do whatever you want
to. Here is where I lay it down. Every
burden, every crown. This is my
surrender. This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay it down. Every lie
and every doubt, this is my surrender.
And I will make room for
you to to do whatever you want
to, to do whatever you want
to. And I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to. to do whatever you want
[Music]
to. So shake up the ground of all my
tradition. Break down the walls of all
my religion. Your way is better.
Your way is
better. Shake up the ground of all my
tradition. Break down the walls of all
my religion. Your way is
better. Your way is
[Music]
better. So shake up the ground of all my
tradition. Break down the walls of all
my religion. Your way is better.
Your way is
better. Shake up the ground of all my
tradition. Break down the walls of all
my religion. Your way is
[Music]
better. Your way is
better. And I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to. to do whatever you want
to. And I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to. To do whatever you want
to. Here is where I lay it down. You are
all I'm chasing now. This is my
surrender. This is my
surrender. Here is where I lay it down.
You are all I'm chasing now. This is my
surrender. This is my surrender.
[Music]
I'm caugh up in your
presence and I just want to sit here at
your
feet. I'm caugh up in this
holy moment.
I never want to
leave. And I'm not here for
blessing. Jesus, you don't owe
me more than
anything that you can do.
I just want you
[Music]
and I'm
sorry when I've just gone through the
motions. I'm sorry
when I just sang another song. Take me
back to where we started. I open up my
heart to you
[Music]
and I'm
sorry when I've come with my
agenda. I'm
sorry when I forgot that you're enough.
Take me back to where we started.
I open up my
heart to you.
I'm caught up. I'm caught up in your
[Music]
presence. And I just want to sit here at
your
feet. I'm caught up in this
holy moment.
I never want to leave.
And I'm not here for
blessings. Jesus, you don't owe me
anything more than
anything that you can do.
I just want you.
[Music]
I just want
you. Nothing
else. Nothing
else. Nothing else will
do. I just want
you. Nothing else.
Nothing
else, nothing else will
do. I just want
you. Nothing
else. Nothing
else. Nothing else will
do. I just want
you. Nothing else.
[Music]
Nothing else,
Jesus. Nothing else will do.
[Music]
Oh yeah. Woah woah woah woah woah woah
woah woah woah
[Music]
woah. I'm caught up in your
presence and I just want to sit here at
your
feet. I'm caught up in this
holy
moment. I never want to leave.
[Music]
Jesus, as we worship you today, as we
center on
you and who you
are and what your journey to the cross
means to
us, we remember that you are with us.
that you were broken for
us, that you are not a far off and
distant God, but you are one that
came, that experienced our lives, that
poured himself out on behalf of
us because of your great
love, because of
love. Not because of our shame, but
because you love
us. And no matter what we have done or
what we could do to measure
up, you said that we are
good. You call us forward.
[Music]
You strengthen our
roots. You turn us into oaks of
righteousness. You make us messengers of
good news and hope and peace to a broken
[Music]
world. Would we meet with that Jesus
tonight?
the one who is still transforming us and
renewing us and calling us to
himself to a God who has not given up on
her
[Music]
work. We love
you and we just want more of you.
[Music]
It's in Jesus name that we close this
time together.
Amen. Thank you guys for worshiping with
us. If y'all will turn to the people
around you and say hello and then Brett
will come up and start the message.
in the season of Lent. Though, you know,
I must admit that time is starting to
wind down as we uh we come into now, of
course, Holy Week. And um I do encourage
you uh to really be engaged with uh with
Christ and with our church community.
This week we're going to join in with uh
Sax First um who they have their Good
Friday service sort of a canata style
kind of heavy music and uh for their
Good Friday and I encourage you to be
here. It'll be 7 o'clock on Friday and
uh and of course the following day we
celebrate Easter here. Um and uh since
of the rental situation and stuff, it's
better for us to do it on Saturday. So
we'll be here same time five o'clock
with a meal to follow and it'll just be
really really um special. So uh and a
free meal. So like now usually we do
potlucks here you know to help with the
budget but this Easter we're like you
know let's just go all in. So we got
some delicious olive garden uh catered
for you and it'll be a really really
good time. So um encourage you to to be
here um for that. So uh the title of my
message uh this Palm Sunday is Christ is
Born. Christ is Born. And I do wish I
could take credit for this little uh
this this little turn of phrase here
because you'll notice it's of course B O
R N E uh in which means like held or
carried as opposed to BN that would be
more you know Advent Christmas uh kind
of theme and uh I say I wish I could
take credit because it was the
theologian Chris Green who I heard uh
kind of talk about it in this way and I
was like oh that's so clever I need to
steal that for my Palm Sunday message.
And um so our our scripture today is
going to be Luke chapter 19 uh
28-38. And uh it's you know it won't
surprise you though the text is of
course the whole Palm Sunday kind of
theme. So verse 28, after Jesus had said
this, he went on ahead going up to
Jerusalem. And as he approached Beth
Page and Bethany at the hill called the
Mount of Olives,
uh he sent two of his disciples, saying
to them, "Go to the village ahead of
you, and as you enter it, you will find
a colt tied there, which no one has ever
ridden. Untie it and bring it here. If
anyone asks you, "Why are you untying
it?" Say, "The Lord needs it." Those who
were sent ahead went and found it just
as he had told them. As they were
untying the colt, its owners asked them,
"Why are you untying the colt?" They
replied, "The Lord needs it." They
brought it to Jesus, threw their cloaks
on the colt, and put Jesus on it. As he
went along, people spread their cloaks
on the road. When he came near the place
where the road goes down the Mount of
Olives, the whole crowd of disciples
began joyfully to praise God in loud
voices for all the miracles they had
seen. Blessed is the King who comes in
the name of the Lord. Peace in heaven
and glory in the
highest. So, I want to reflect a little
more deeply on Chris Green's phrase here
and he actually kind of took it from a a
quote by uh the famous theologian St.
Augustine who said this, which do you
want to be? The one who untied the full
or the full
itself? In other words, do you want to
be the disciples who obey Jesus or the
one who who carries him who who bears
Christ?
And I I love this uh this kind of image
here because of like really the way to
read scripture well, right, is to really
enter into the story. And uh I I must
admit um well, I should say more about
the story thing. So like this goes deep
in the church's kind of history and
liturgy. Uh even going back like if you
uh for example are here, it won't be
actually this service on Good Friday. I
don't think they do this style um of
service, but there's certain churches
where at Good Friday, right, the day of
the cross, the whole community shouts
out, "Crucify him. Crucify him." Right?
So, it's this sort of um
immersive we're we're kind of entering
into the story. We're we're seeing
ourselves as the various characters. And
uh of course, what we all just did,
right? Entering marching around the
sanctuary.
and all that um can strike us, you know,
some of us a little strange. Admittedly,
it is. Um but that's the that's sort of
the point, right? Is to do our best not
just to kind of read scripture or study
scripture or hear a sermon this kind of
detached objective way, you know, but to
to really enter in to to immerse
ourselves in the story. Um, but the
thing I'd never considered in reading
this passage or uh celebrating Palm
Sunday, like I had seen myself as the
disciples. I had seen myself in the role
of like the crowd. I had never not for
one second ever considered myself as the
cult, as this offspring of the donkey
carrying Christ. Uh but I mean if you
kind of think of it spiritually
speaking, right? Not too literally. Um I
think it's it's a beautiful kind of
image. I mean isn't this sort of what
we're called to do, right? To carry
Christ to others. So uh with that kind
of in mind, I'm going to share kind of a
few reflections on this uh with you. So
first notice the cult's role is to make
Jesus available to others, right? In
other words, the people, right, they
need Christ. They they need uh worship.
They need hope. They need peace. That
they need uh to use kind of the more
traditional language, they need to to be
saved, right? Saved from their greed,
from their fear, from from their trauma
and and a past that kind of haunts us,
right? We they need to be saved from
this. And so you'll notice it's the
cult's job not to like fix them, fix the
people. No, instead the cult's job is
simply to carry Christ to
them to to carry the one who
can do all of those things for them. to
kind of translate that, you know, out of
the story and more into our lives, we
might say um that we are the the bearers
of the spirit of God. And that what
people really need isn't so much like
our
cleverness, you know, our smarts, our
intelligence, or we really know a lot
about the Bible or theology or whatever
and we're going to make sure they get
their thinking changed correctly, you
know. Um no, no. But what what people
really need is the healing presence of
God channeled in and through us. 2
Corinthians chapter 4:7 puts it this
way. But we have this treasure in jars
of clay to show that this all surpassing
power is from God and not from us. So
here Paul doesn't mean that we've
captured God in these little clay pots
and we're going to give you know God to
people. Um, of course it's instead he
means in essence uh you are the jar of
clay and as we spoke of a few weeks ago
uh what this means is you are this
physical body right but but you are
animated by a spiritual body animated by
divinity the very presence of
Christ and so ultimately it's never us
we never like fix or heal or save
anyone. Like that's always the work of
the healing power of God in and through
us. So I realize some of this language a
little more traditional but maybe even
this idea of carrying Christ to others.
Um you know there's many interpretations
of this, right? We can kind of you might
be hearing this in different ways and uh
some of them even may maybe ways that
are a little un unhelpful. Um I mean I
think for example we kind of have we
tend to have in our mind a certain ideal
you know like an the ideal Christian. Uh
and so then we're like okay so I need to
you know be live up to this ideal. I
need to be this this great cult carrying
Christ to others. And I think we get a
little a little wonky um at this point.
Right. So you might be hearing me and
thinking like okay yeah I'm tracking
bread. I'm tracking. So I need to be an
evangelist. All right. Right? I need to
get out there and I need to um carry
certain ideas, right? In essence, it
becomes a very verbal thing. I I need to
speak. I need to tell people certain
doctrines, certain ideas, um c a certain
narrative about, right, the life, the
death, and resurrection of Jesus. And
this is where it really can start to get
wonky, and kind of convince them to
believe it, right? Um I I must become a
door-todoor evangelist.
Uh maybe that's where your mind's going.
Um and and again, not that that would be
bad like to be an evangelist or to share
Christ, but but you can you see where it
can start to get a little skewed, right?
It becomes very verbal, very idea
driven, uh a little off or maybe uh in
your mind went to being like a
missionary. At least when I was a child,
this was like the ultimate. If you want
to be a true cult
carrying Christ to the nations, you
know, you need to get out of dodge and
you need to go somewhere where you don't
want to be, you know, or something and
just and make the true sacrifice, you
know, for years. I really looking back,
I was sweet little bread. I really I
think I had a good heart. But when
people would ask me like, "What do you
want to be when you grow up?" And this
is like six, seven, eight, you know, I'd
always say a missionary. I want to be a
missionary. You know, I think it was
good-hearted, but I think some of it was
this idea. You know, I knew that's like
the highest thing, you know, the biggest
sacrifice, the most committed, you know.
Um, though maybe those examples, I don't
know. I get those are a little more
traditional and, you know, I know the
crowd here. Uh, Ryan's maybe not going
to those places. Um, I mean, another one
that's probably more relevant in like
the last 20 years of like church kind of
our Protestant history and such is um
our buzzwords like
leadership, you know, that's like the
the thing where babe I don't know
evangelist missionary or people really
want to be that I don't know but like
leader a church a leader you know that's
like the thing uh that's when you're
really you know if you got a microphone
then you if you're on the stage then you
know you're like really carrying Christ
to others. I uh number of years ago I
had this uh interesting experience. I
was part of a Christmas production um at
a kind of an area DFW kind of area
um mega church and not even like a mega
church like a few thousand people but
like I mean a mega mega it's like the
biggest church I've ever it is literally
one of the biggest churches in the
United States not just like Texas like
it's huge and uh it was really weird for
me. I was in the throws of
deconstruction at that time. I didn't
know what I believed or I've seen sort
of all the problematic things of
Christian history and theology and I was
just I was upside down, you know, but we
had babies and I needed some money, you
know. So, they're like, "We'll pay you
to sing a song, you know." So, I was
like, "Okay." So, show up there and um
it was fascinating because I got a
little bit like behind the scenes and I
got to be in the green
room. You ever been in a green room?
Christian green room. Yeah. Well, I have
once in my time, you know. Um, so it's
basically, right, churches where you
have multiple services. Um, it becomes a
kind of space for the I mean, at its
best, it's just a place, a kind of
practical place where people who are
there for like seven hours can like get
some food. You know, I mean, I get it.
It does. It's hard for it not to become
a kind of thing, you know? Are you
allowed in the green room? Are you here
to Okay, that's for the talent. No, you
can't go eating those cookies. That's
for the talent, you know, in the church.
like it it just you know becomes that
and the whole vibe there. It got weird
like when the pastor when a certain
person or a key, you know, would walk in
like the kind of fawning and the you
know I mean it was just the weirdest
vibes and I was like oh no right but
this is sort of what we do you know we
we have these ideals these these people
we think oh that's who we need to be or
become or and we just get all weird
about it and I think it ends up being
sort of um I don't know either it's like
one of two extremes either either we
start denigrating ourselves down like
we're failures, we're not living up,
we're not I'm not, you know, enough. Or
it's a sort of weird I am enough and
then it's like Christian ego, you know,
sort of masquerading as piety. Um, but
that's sort of what I'm driving at,
right? We just get all these crazy ideas
in our head. And
uh what I want you to notice though in
the story, this is the second point, is
that the cult does
nothing
extraordinary, which I kind of love it.
It is just simply itself. It's like my
job is to be the cult. You know what I
mean? Just the cult just cults. That's
it. You know, it just kind of walks. Uh
but but in doing that, right, in being
itself, what does it do? It carries
Christ. It bears Christ to others. The
further I journey on this Christian
path, the more I start I kind of find
myself thinking like it's the
way. That's
it. That's not that's it like oh that's
all you are God. This is not not that
that's actually I would say more
profound than I would have realized that
that's it is that's all you wanted of
me.
like you just wanted me to be
myself and
then to
love like I mean it sounds so stupidly
simple but sometimes you have to have a
long journey to end up at that
simplicity you know sort of the
simplicity on the other side of
complexity and you got to kind of go
through it and and this is really the
experience I kind of spent decades like
twisting myself into knots not trying to
be a worthy cult of the Lord or you know
whatever. Like there was even years
where I thought I would never pastor
again because I'm not an ideal pastor in
my brain.
Um, not I I'm not a big risktaker, not
super
entrepreneurial, like I'm just not the
even hard charging leader like, "Hey
everyone, I've got a big goal and a
dream and a vision. Follow me, you know,
and I'm just not the kind of person, you
know, and you know that's in kind of
recent church history, that's sort of
the ideal pastor, you know, but but it's
it's these ideals again." And of course,
it's different for everyone, right? I'm
not saying I know you had that
experience like yours is different but
we just we get ourselves twisted and we
feel like we have to be someone so
different than we are. Um instead of
realizing like no no no God God loves
you and made you just who you are and
and the spirit's going to just use
exactly who you are right here right
now. There's a a wonderful quote from
the theologian Elaine Heath where she
kind of summarized Christian Christian
life and like ministry in this way. She
said it's just this. Show
up, pay
attention, cooperate with God, release
the
outcome. I love that. Like that's sort
of your whole life, you know, just sort
of summarize right there. Just show up.
Pay attention to the pay attention is
interesting because it's sort of a a
tune in, right? Because you can be in a
place and you're not there. Your mind
like you're just like whatever. What do
these people think of me or you know? So
it's no no. Shut up. Pay attention. Just
cooperate with what God's doing. And
then the key release those outcomes.
Well, that's what trips. I don't know
about you, but that's what trips me up.
I'm like, no, but I need them to think
this way and I need that to be this. You
know, I know release the
outcomes. It sounds almost too simple,
but really I think that is like the key
to all good living and relating. I mean,
want to be a good parent, show up, pay
attention, cooperate with the Holy
Spirit as best you can, release those
outcomes. That's tough, you know, want
to be a good partner. Same thing. Want
to be a good, you know, ministry leader
or someone leading a small group or or
just a good person in the world, you
know, show up in these kinds of ways.
Now, I think that's where it's kind of
simple because you can think to yourself
like, wait, that's it. But like, at
least this is where my mind used to go.
Like, but when do I um when do I freak
out? When do I
strive? You know, when do I really make
that sacrifice? And I hate it. And I
hate every second, but it's all going to
be worth it because at the end, I'm
going to arrive somewhere else and be
someone so different than I, you know
what I mean? Um, no, no, no,
no. We're more like, uh, maybe a good
metaphor is uh like a gardener, you
know, and the gardener, the gardener
does things. gardener shows up, does
some tilling, does some watering, does
you? But like ultimately, who is it that
makes that garden grow? It's not the
gardener. He's like, "All right, and now
for my magic, you know, like, no, that's
the spirit of God. That's that's the the
Lord who gives life and breath to all
things, who's animating you and me and
all creation." And like that's that's
God's
work. I I kind of have in mind here um
again as opposed to sort of that classic
evangelist, missionary, leader, this
that or whatever other ideals we have, I
have something more in mind. There's a
quote from a therapist named Ba uh
Bonnie Baden, and there's a quote. She's
actually she's like in a podcast, so
it's it's very off the cuff. You can
tell in the writing it's not some
flawless quote, you know, um sort of
conversational, but it really gets at
something. She says this, "One of the
things I try to do is to offer a sense
of what true presence feels like.
non-judgmental agendalous experience of
being
received. Oh, that I freaking love that.
The agendalous experience of just being
received. That's what we hope for. And
that really is a spiritual state. I love
that she tunes into that. That it's like
that's that's God. You know what I mean?
Like that's the spirit like doing a
thing.
If we can come towards each other in a
non-judgmental way, but asking like who
who are you and all of that, that kind
of receptivity is a lot of what
mindfulness practice and lots of
spiritual lives are actually centered
in. She continues, "These days, you
know, I'm getting older and I'm
thinking, what I really want to be is a
therapeutic presence in the world with a
bank teller, with the kid delivering a
newspaper, being present in that way so
that they can feel their
value." Oh, I think that's so
beautifully put. And wouldn't the the
world be better if the church understood
that to say I want to bear Christ today
or I want to have the mind of Christ. I
want to be full of the spirit. I want to
be used by God today. Is really to say I
want to be a therapeutic healing
presence in the world.
I I want to bring love. I want to bring
presence. I I want people to have that
that sense of of that that unconditional
agendous just being
received. Being received just for who
they
are. Something so powerful in
that. And that may I don't know maybe
that strikes you as a little bit strange
but I I think in essence like if you
think even of what so much of therapy is
of course therapist has you know
training and knowledge and there's
different types that can be kind of more
or a little bit less of this but in the
end
um what are they doing? They're they're
showing up and they're paying attention
and they're cooperating with the spirit
of God and they're releasing the
outcomes right and And in essence, like
that's our work too in its own way,
right? And it shouldn't be too shocking
that in essence, it's all the same work,
right? You could say to use Paul's
metaphor, we're all different parts of
the body of Christ, right? Different
gifts, different expressions. Um, and
yet in the end, we're all just showing
up, paying attention, cooperating with
God, and releasing those outcomes.
It's the same work. There's um I think
when I think of folks in our community,
I mean of course I could talk about
almost every person or every person in
their own ways, but I think of for
example Allison um Huffwood who's doing
the work of um prepping things like our
potluck meals when we do those um
service opportunities at Five Loaves
Food Pantry and uh what a godsend she's
been to me since I was trying to do some
of those things in the past very poorly
and inconsistently. And so she's really
come along to help us do that. And I
mean in essence, what is she doing,
right? She would just say, "I'm just
doing, you know, what I feel called to
do. I have a certain gifting or
whatever." Uh, but that's it's a big
deal. She's carrying she's bearing
Christ to us and she's empowering us.
I'm thinking specifically like five
loaves and these service opportunities
to carry Christ to others, right? It it
matters.
Uh, someone I I almost never talk about,
but um I should, is my wife Maggie.
Maggie Tilford right here. I'm gonna
probably embarrass her, but I mean she
is like she's like the ultimate um she
has a few things she does up front that
she plays keys and things like so a
little upfront, but so much of what she
does is just behind the scenes like
invisible, especially to many of the
adults in the room. pretty invisible uh
teaching and kids uh ministry and
leading that team uh leading our youth
ministry. And then there's all the
things no one sees except me. All of the
like meeting with people for coffee and
the checking in and the text messages.
It's like an endless stream. And I don't
know how she handles it. I would just
start screaming at my phone like, "Oh my
god, I can't do this." But somehow just
like ding ding ding ding. Um, and she
just keeps resp. It may take her a
while. Some of you know like, okay, it
might be a day, you know, but she's
going to get back to you. And like that
kind of just love like what's she doing
there? It's not just about, oh, she's
what a nice person. Oh, yeah. But this
is about she's carrying Christ to us.
She's bearing Christ to
us. I think finally, I'll close with
this one beautiful expression um in our
community recently. uh this person's has
all their stuff has been anonymous so I
won't mention their name but they're an
artist in our community and uh this is
not the kind of person who would want to
be you know upfront like give me that
microphone and you know that kind of
person um and yet over the past it's
been at least a year maybe two um they
have like when they hear someone's like
going through something um or someone
just discouraged or she just even if she
doesn't hear but she just um senses it
you know
um that she also will she'll do some
kind of art thing for them. Sometimes
it's as simple as like a stone with some
little painting or a word or you know
something. And uh I know about this
because at times I've been the one that
she's asked me to like give it to
someone, you know, to deliver. And and
I've seen people like receive these
gifts. Sometimes it's a car just
artfully drawn, you know, and people
like I mean it's incredible the
reaction. It feels so so
personal what what's happening there
like becoming this this conduit of the
spirit to people and it's and that's
what makes a church community, right?
And that's honestly even beyond a church
me. That's what makes a community, a
family, uh a broader tribe. Like if you
don't have those kinds of things like
that kind of love expressed
like you got
nothing. This all this stuff matters. It
matters. So the heart of it really is
please don't discount
yourself. Don't do it. Don't dis
discount your gifts, your your sense of
call, your whatever how no matter how
small or whatever it may seem like those
kinds of gestures, those actions, those
calls and texts and and serving in that
small way or going here, going there,
like caring for people that you are
bearing Christ to others. So church,
that's the message this Palm
Sunday, following God. So simple, so
beautiful. Show
up. Pay attention. Cooperate with
God. Release those outcomes in the name
of the Father, the Son, and the Holy
Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night that Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, He held up
a loaf of bread and then he broke it and
he said, "Take it and eat. This is my
body. It's broken for you." And he held
up a cup of wine. He said, "This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me. Remember me." So, as
we come forward today, that's that's
what we're doing. we're
participating in uh that ancient
practice and and sacrament. So the way
we go about this tonight is we're just
going to keep it simple. We'll go row by
row. So we'll start here at the front.
We'll form one line here in the middle.
So as one row finishes, the next line
can go ahead and get up. Um you should
know the red is wine, the white is grape
juice. And then finally, um you can
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks like to come and meal, others
like to partake right away. will return
to their seats, but no one will lead you
through the exact moment of of partaking
of the elements. So, this is the table,
not of the church, but of the
Lord. And it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more. So,
come you who have much
faith and you who have little, you have
been here often and you who have not
been here long. You who have tried to
follow and you who feel like you just
failed, come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should be here. Come to the table.
[Music]
for this um last song that we're doing.
Jesse's going to get us started in just
a second. Um but I wanted to ask you
guys to stand with us for this last one.
We don't always stand during the last
song, but this one in particular has
been sort of part of a bedrock
foundational song for the table. Um, and
I love especially on this Holy Week and
as we think about the journey that Jesus
is about to make towards the cross, I
just hear him saying these words to us.
Um, because when things are the darkest,
sometimes we need to be reminded to hold
on, to not give up because Christ is
doing a good work in us. Um, so let's
encourage ourselves and one another.
know, we're not always like the
touchiest church, so I'm not going to
make you like join hands across the
aisle, although I'm tempted to. I have
been very into handholding lately, and
my team can tell you. I I vowed not to
do that tonight. But in my heart, I we
are all holding hands as we sing this
song. Okay, in my heart. So, if you can
imagine us joining together as a
community and encouraging one another
with these words to hold on a little
longer and hope in the Lord. All right,
Jesse, you can get us started.
[Music]
Blessed are the
ones and all the broken pieces of their
heart.
[Music]
Blessed are the tears of all the
weery. Pouring like a sky, falling
stars.
Blessed are the wounded ones
[Music]
in brave enough to show the Lord their
scars.
Blessed are the hurt that are not
hidden. Open to the healing touch of
God. The kingom is yours.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
[Music]
Blessed are the ones who walk in
kindness even in the face of great
[Music]
abuse. Blessed are the deeds that go
unnoticed, serving with unguarded
gratitude.
[Music]
Blessed are the ones who fight for
justice, longing for the coming day of
peace.
Blessed is the soul that thirsts for
righteousness, welcoming the last, the
lost, the least.
The kingom is
[Music]
yours. The kingom is
yours. Hold on a little more. This is
not the end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
The kingom is yours.
The kingom is
yours. Hold on a little more. This is
not the end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
Oh.
[Music]
Oh. Oh.
Blessed are the ones who suffer
violence and still have strength to love
their
enemies. Blessed is the faith of those
who
persevere. Though they fall, they'll
never know defeat.
The kingom is yours.
The kingom is
yours. Hold on a little more. This is
not the end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
The kingom is yours.
[Music]
The kingom is
yours. Hold on a little more. This is
not the end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end. Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes
on him.
[Music]
Well, thank you all so much for joining
us this
evening. Uh if you're new, we'd surely
like for you to fill out a little card
on the table or on your way out or scan
the QR code and fill out the online
visitors
card. Stuffed Easter eggs. You know,
during our service Saturday the 19th,
we're having an Easter egg hunt for the
kiddos. And if you haven't had a chance
to donate stuffed eggs, then you can
send Maggie Maggie Tilford a donation VM
Mozelle her cell phone number so she can
purchase the candy and eggs for the
kids. We want it to be an abundant
Easter.
[Music]
Today starts what we call Holy Week. As
Brett mentioned in his sermon, uh there
are a couple of special services
happening and we hope that you can join
us for Good Friday. Well, we'll be
attending here at First Saxi at 700 p.m.
on April the 18th. And then our Easter
service will be the next day, Saturday,
April the 19th at 5:00 PM, followed by a
family meal. Everyone is welcome to stay
afterwards and
eat. All right, our first Sunday is
going to be May the 4th, and we're going
to try something a little bit different,
new with our worship gathering. Uh we're
going to gather in the family life
center for the entire time of our
worship. It'll be a great opportunity to
connect and share. So again, the QR
code, sign up, contribute to the meal,
look for the link tree there.
[Music]
Okay. Now, let me send you into your
week with this blessing.
Uh you can hold out your hands in a
gesture of receiving or you can just
open your heart to these words or you
can do all of
it. Here we
go. You are a child of
God. You Yes, you are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day. So, as you go
into your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between, go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved, that you are
worthy, and you are accepted just as you
are. and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same gifts of grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come in contact
with and connect with them. Be blessed
and we'll see you next Saturday.
[Music]
yours. The kingom is yours.